joining us now with more we have former
LAPD detective Fox News contributor Mark
Fuhrman former FBI special agent Manny
Gomez mark I've known you a lot over the
years we don't often disagree you see a
couple of flaws in what I think I just
you're never gonna convince an anti-gun
person to be pro Second Amendment and
similarly I've carried a weapon almost
all my adult life I've had carry permits
in in New York California Alabama
Georgia and Rhode Island I've had carry
permit I've had it's part of I was
trained since I'm 11 in the use of a
firearm so you're not gonna win on that
debate but securing the schools with the
professionals to me is a thousand
percent doable and we owe it to the kids
to do this we do we do and the only
thing that I don't disagree with you I
just think that there's a better
approach when you have retired personnel
they have the best part of their career
behind them and you need a generational
gap that isn't two or three generations
perhaps this better part of one these
officers on the school need to be able
to interact with these students and get
that information that a guy like Cruz
what a surface and they would have
actually confided in the officer you
need to get some kind of a system where
you have protocols for all these schools
so everybody is working off the same
sheet of music and you need to harden
the inside target so the suspect can't
get in and you create the tactical
situation for a shooter on the outside
which allows responding officers and the
security officers to take out the
suspect with no danger to the students I
think this is all possible without gun
control I all of it is and strategically
and tactically look my guess manny is
you're gonna have retired military
retired police or maybe active and I
think you can even work in in
conjunction with local law enforcement
to get this done and again it would be
concealed carry
I would think these probably a lot of
people a lot of the students will become
friends with these guys over time and
Marc's right we can get a lot of
intelligence from them
but strategically tactically you
surround the perimeter you have a full
threat assessment security assessment
all we know the entry point at any point
and all of this everybody gets in is
known nobody that is unknown gets into
that school period end of sentence
it seems doable if we if we choose to do
it I totally agree having the experience
of former military former law
enforcement we just had a wonderful
piece where the Cultch
from this high school save lives this is
a coach that knew these students he was
a father figure perhaps certainly an
adult figure to these young men and
women that's what we need we need people
that these young people will respect
look up to if they have problems whether
it's a active shooter situation or an
award a day to day basis a drug
condition of criminal condition of
bullying condition they will go up to
these former law enforcement all-america
former military role models and be able
to discuss with them what they could do
to help the situation so it'll be a
win-win-win on a daily basis if they're
there every day I look I was a kid
smoking in the bathroom I got to know
the janitors everybody because they
wouldn't rat me out for when I was young
and stupid but but in all seriousness
they're gonna get to know these kids
those kids are gonna open up to them and
all the things we've heard that the kids
are now saying post the shooting these
guys will have heard earlier and they
they would be they have the training and
a knowledge and and how to intervene in
a situation like that agreed no III
agree Shawn when you have when you have
somebody that's inside a system like a
school you have to not only have
security you have to be able to have
investigative skills to be able to very
effectively and sometimes under the
radar investigate some of these problems
that you see or that are reported to you
but just remember that
security from the protection of the
President to anything that the FBI does
the Israelis anybody will tell you
security is a layered event it's not
just one you have layers of security so
you always contemplate a failure of one
or something that fails or something has
taken out you need a layer of security
no matter what and a school especially
all right thank you both if every
American demands us in their district we
will have safer schools thousand percent
safer